robert spencer andy cyrus was on with me
uh last week and
we discussed the fact that muslim
candidates in record numbers are running
for office and being elected and
frequently being faced with a choice
between the laws
of the federal government and the state
governments
specifically the u.s constitution and
sharia what do they choose robert
when the two
conflict
well this is a very important question
and every individual muslim candidate
would have to be
giving an answer in a sane society and
then we would see
uh
where they come down some of them would
no doubt side with the constitution and
some with sharia but the fact is that
reporters don't dare to ask the question
it's considered islamophobic in itself
and so we don't get any answers about
any of the candidates and i can tell you
give you an example of how this can be
damaging rashad hussein is not a
candidate for elected office he is the
biden administration's appointee to head
the u.s institute on religious freedom
now
if he is confirmed and he becomes the
head of the institute on religious
freedom he is a hafiz who has memorized
the entire quran and so clearly he's a
very devout believing
muslim
and so the quran says that muslims
should fight to subjugate jews and
christians under the rule of islamic law
and that
you should be ruthless to the
unbelievers muhammad it's in chapter 48
verse 29 muhammad is the apostle of
allah those who follow him are merciful
to one another and ruthless to
unbelievers so if he sees
christians being mistreated in pakistan
or egypt or non-muslims being mistreated
in iran or elsewhere
is he going to think well we should be
ruthless to unbelievers this is what
allah wants or is he going to uphold
american principles now this is a very
important question about his appointment
but here again
he ain't ever going to be asked
you